hey everyone welcome to this next
episode of your daily equation i hope
you're doing well
it is cold and rainy where i am
at the moment maybe where you are the
weather is better or at least it's
pretty
outside i can't complain of course about
the context in which i find myself these
days
and i'd like to do today is focus upon
the big bang and the
notion that space is expanding these are
ideas that
emerged in the early part of the 20th
century after albert einstein wrote down
his equations of the general theory of
relativity so i'll take you through a
little bit of the
history of thinking along those lines
and then i'll show you a bit of the
mathematics that
leads to these conclusions i won't spell
out every last detail
maybe in subsequent episodes i will i
just really want to give you
a feel for how it can be
that equations can tell you something
like the universe
is expanding or contracting or that
there
should have been a big bang at time zero
where in the mathematics can you find
these kinds of conclusions all right so
let me begin
with just a little bit of the history of
these ideas let me bring up
some stuff here on the screen
good okay so this guy over here
george lemaitre may be a familiar name
to you
but he's not necessarily a household
name
or actually not a household name that
i'm pretty certain about
he was a belgian priest who had the
unusual distinction
of earning a phd in physics from mit
and also obviously being a priest
and those are usually fields that
we envision as being whatever
antagonists at odds with each other they
by no means need to be case in point
right here
and so it was quite natural that when
lemaitre learned that einstein
had come up with this new description of
the force of gravity and again the force
of gravity is the force that
is most relevant over the
large scales of the universe right so
naturally if you are interested in the
big
questions of existence you want to apply
einstein's new insight to the biggest
possible example which of course is the
universe as a whole
and that's what le maitre did and he
came to the conclusion and i'll show you
more or less why
he came to that conclusion he came to
the conclusion that the universe could
not
be static right the going
philosophical prejudice at the time
was that on the largest of scales the
universe was fixed eternal static
unchanging right there obviously is
change
in the local environment right you see
the moon
moving you see the you see the sun
moving but you interpret it as the earth
in orbit around the sun so there's
obviously change in the local
environment
but the view was that on average if you
average that out
over sufficiently large scales that
there would be no overall change
right i mean it's you know i don't have
my earl gray here today so i have to do
a thought experiment but
you know as you've seen when i have my
earl grey and my soy milk it's got this
muddy brown color and it looks static
and unchanging if you were to go
sufficiently deep
into that cup of earl grey you'd find
that all the molecules of water 10
whatever they're all bouncing around so
there's a lot of motion
a lot of change happening on small
scales
within the cup of tea but when you
average it out
on the scale of a cup it doesn't look
like anything is happening at all so the
view was that the local motion
motion of moons planets things in the
local environment
that's like the motion of the molecules
inside the cup of tea
but average it out over sufficiently
large scales and just like the cup of
tea you will find
that on sufficiently large scales the
universe is unchanging that was the
prevailing view
so when lemaitre came to the startling
conclusion
that einstein's math when applied to the
entire universe says the fabric of space
is stretching
or contracting but not simply staying
put
that was going against the grain of most
people's intuition most people's
expectation
so the major brought this idea
to einstein they spoke i believe this is
the 1927 solve a
conference and einstein's
response is a famous one i think i
mentioned it in a previous episode
einstein said to
the major something like your
calculations
are correct but your physics is
abominable
and what he was basically saying is sure
you know you can do calculations
using various equations in this case
einstein's own equations
but it's not the case that every
calculation that you do
is necessarily relevant to reality
einstein was saying you've got to have
sort of
an artist's intuition to figure out
which of the configurations and
combinations and calculations that you
do with the equations is
actually truly relevant to
the physical world now the reason why
einstein could say that lament's
calculations were correct is
more or less because einstein had
already seen
those calculations earlier number one
einstein did his own version of applying
his equations to the entire universe
i'll make reference to that at the end
but in particular this guy over here
alexander friedman
russian physicist he some years earlier
had actually written a paper
on showing that einstein's equations
apply
that the universe is say stretching or
contracting
and at that time einstein himself wrote
a little response to
friedman's paper where he said that
friedman's calculations were wrong
now you can imagine it's pretty tough
when albert einstein
grades your paper and says that the
calculations
are wrong but friedman was no pushover
he
knew that he was right and he stayed
with it and he wrote
einstein a letter establishing in his
mind that the calculations were
correct einstein i believe was on a trip
to japan at the time so he didn't see
the letter when it first arrived but
friedman implored a friend of einstein's
to really get einstein to read
the letter i'm pretty sure this history
is correct i'm going a little bit by
well completely by memory here i hope
it's real memory
and einstein did read the letter and
finally
came to the conclusion that einstein had
himself made a mistake
and that it was friedman's calculations
that were correct
but nevertheless that didn't change
einstein's perspective
that this notion let's say of an
expanding universe a universe that was
changing over time
he still did not think that that was
relevant to
reality right again okay he says the
math is all right
but it's not relevant to
the actual structure of the world what
really changed einstein's perspective
were observations observations by edwin
hubble
edwin hubble used the powerful telescope
at mount
wilson observatory to conclude
that the distant galaxies are not
staying put the distant galaxies are all
rushing
away and that outward motion of all the
galaxies
was clear evidence that
the universe is not static and
you can even see a little bit of of some
of hubble's data i think i have it over
here so this graph
over here shows the relationship between
the distance that a galaxy is from
us and the speed with which it is
receding
from us and you see that there's this
nice curve here which basically is
telling us that
the farther away the galaxy is
the quicker it is rushing away from us
so its speed of recession is
proportional to
its distance and it turns out and i'll
give you a little visual
in half a second that is exactly the
relationship
that you would expect if space
itself is expanding if space itself is
expanding
then the speed with which two points in
space
move apart due to the swelling of space
is proportional
to their separation and
i'll give you a little example right now
it's the familiar one
that you've probably seen a million
times but
it's not it's not perfect but it's a
pretty
good way of thinking about this notion
of how it can be that every object can
rush away from
every other that's sort of a strange
idea if you think about it you think
that some are rushing away they're
heading toward others
no they're all rushing away from each
other and moreover the speed of
recession
is proportional to the distance this
helps you get your mind around that what
is the analogy of course it is the
famous
balloon analogy where we imagine
that the surface of a balloon is the
entirety of the universe just the
surface the rubber
part the stretchy part of the balloon
that is the analogy we imagine that that
is all there is that is the entirety of
the universe
and you imagine that you have galaxies
that
are drawn on the surface of this balloon
and as the balloon stretches you can see
how the galaxies move relative to
one another so let me just show you so
here it is so we have this balloon you
see the galaxy
is over there and the idea is as you
blow air into the balloon
everything moves away from everything
else so i can even make that a little
bit
more precise by putting a little grid on
the balloon so you see this grid has
a unit of one unit of separation
between the grid lines and now
let's see what happens when we blow air
in and what i want you to focus your
attention on
the two lower galaxies are one unit
apart
the two galaxies right above it are two
units apart
and those two galaxies at the upper edge
of the grid they're
three units apart so one unit two unit
three units let's now
blow the balloon up stretch it some so
it gets
larger there it goes
now the galaxies that were one unit
apart
are now two units apart the galaxies
that were
two units apart are now four units apart
and the upper two galaxies that were
three units apart
are now two plus two plus two are now
six units apart
so you see that the speed with which the
galaxies receded
is proportional to their initial
distance
because to go from one unit to two
that's a certain speed
but to go from two units to four it's
got to be double the speed
this all happens in the same period of
time as the balloon stretches
to go from three units apart to six
units apart
in the same period of time you have to
have three times the velocity
of the two lower galaxies so there you
see
that the speed of recession is
proportional
to the separation is proportional to the
distance so we can compare them right
here
and you see what i was talking about you
went from one to two you went from two
to four
and the upper two galaxies went from
three to six
so this gave substantial evidence
that the universe is expanding
it comes out of einstein's mathematics
the calculations
are correct but the physics is not
abominable
when you have observations that confirm
the mathematical predictions so
this turned einstein around in an
instant
he quickly came to the conclusion that
this picture of the universe was correct
and he kind of slapped himself
metaphorically in the forehead
for not himself coming to this
conclusion
a decade earlier because einstein was
really in the position
to predict one of the most profound
insights about the nature of reality
that space is
expanding he could have made that
prediction something like a dozen years
before
it was observed but be that
as it may what really matters is that we
gain
insight into the nature of the world and
through einstein's mathematics
in the hands of friedman in the matra
confirmed through the observations of
hubble we have this picture of the
expanding universe now
if the universe is currently expanding
well then
you know it doesn't take a rocket
scientist to imagine
winding that cosmic film in reverse
everything today rushing apart go back
in time everything was closer and closer
together
and in this model of the universe that
means that
everything would be back on top of one
another at
time zero that is the big bang and i'll
show you
a picture of that in just a moment but i
do want to address a couple of quick
things about
the balloon metaphor number one
people often say okay
if the universe is expanding where's the
center where's the center of the
expansion now the balloon has a center
of course but it's not on the surface of
balloon it's inside the balloon but this
metaphor requires that we think about
the entirety of reality
to just be the surface of
the balloon the inside of the balloon is
not a point in reality in
using this metaphor and you see that as
the surface stretches
there's no center every galaxy
every point on the balloon is moving
away from every other point on the
balloon there is no special
location on the balloon surface
now it's not hard to capture that idea
in your mind when it comes to the
balloon it's harder
to then extrapolate from this metaphor
to the entirety of space but
i really encourage you to do so because
we believe
that as in this metaphor there is no
center
to the universe every location every
galaxy is moving away from every other
galaxy there's no preferred spot from
which
everything is rushing apart it's not
really like an explosion
in a pre-existing space in which there
really is a center where the explosion
took place
there's no pre-existing space in this
view of cosmology
right as space expands
you get more space it's not that the
space was all
ready there and that's the second point
that i really want to make because
people often say
okay if the universe is expanding tell
me what it's expanding
into and again the intuition is clear
even with the bloom the balloon expands
into our pre-existing space
but for the balloon metaphor to really
grab
hold of you fully again imagine that the
surface of the balloon
represents the entirety of the universe
and so when the balloon expands it's not
expanding into a pre-existing space
because the pre-existing space is not on
the surface of the bloom which is meant
to be in this analogy
the entirety of reality so what does
happen is
as the balloon stretches there's more
space because
the balloon is stretched it's bigger
there's more surface area
on the balloon because of the stretching
similarly there's more volume in our
universe
because of space stretching space is not
expanding into
previously unchartered territory
it's expanding and thereby creating the
new space that it
then contains so those are two subtle
points that i hope
that clarifies a little bit but now let
me
conclude the story this visual version
of cosmology by showing you
what we would envision then for the big
bang so
again run the cosmic film back to the
beginning imagine all of space
again it's very hard to picture this all
of space in this
finite case is compressed to a single
point maybe that's a third
third caveat i should say so in this
example
clearly the balloon has a finite size
so it's imagining that the universe has
an overall
finite volume and therefore if you wind
the film back to the beginning that fine
finite volume that's smaller smaller and
smaller ultimately goes down to
effectively
infinitesimal or zero volume a point
i've made in another episode but let me
just reemphasize it here
if you had a different model
for space an infinite model imagine that
we had
the rubber that makes up the balloon
surface but
it is stretched infinitely far in all
directions
infinitely far then as you stretched it
again you'd have
points receding from each other and the
speed of recession would again be
proportional to their initial separation
but if it was infinitely big not finite
like the sphere
then as you say wind the film backward
and
have things go smaller and smaller and
smaller it would still be infinite in
size
because if you cut infinity down by a
factor 2 say
infinity over 2 is still infinity cut
infinity down by a factor of a thousand
still infinite so that's a key
difference between
the finite shaped version that the
balloon brings to mind
and this harder to picture but perfectly
viable
infinite version of space so when i'm
talking about the big bang right now
i'm going to really use the image of a
finite volume so imagine that all the
space is compressed into a little
tiny nugget it's not existing in a
pre-existing space my visual
may make it look like it's existing in a
pre-existing space because i don't know
how else to represent these kind of
unfamiliar ideas visually but here then
would be
what the big bang would be like
everything is compressed
undergoes this rapid swelling and as
the space gets larger and larger
all of the hot initial primordial plasma
spreads ever
more thinly cools down in structures
like stars
and galaxies can emerge
so that's that's the basic basic image
if you will
of expanding space wind the film back
takes you to this notion of a big bang
now if it was the infinite version of
space not the finite one
then it would basically be infinitely
compressed
at an infinity of locations not at one
location and this big bang would be this
rapid swelling of the entirety
of this infinite expanse
which is a different image to have in
mind but as far as the things that we
have access to
be very similar to this picture because
we don't have access to things that are
infinitely far away
ever it would take an infinite amount of
time for the light
from those locations to reach us we only
ever have access to a finite
volume and therefore the image that i
gave you is a pretty good one
even if the entirety of reality were to
be
infinite okay so that's that's the the
visual version and what i want to finish
up with here
is to just give you some of the
the basic mathematics behind
what we're talking about here so i won't
again go through
every last detail but i do want you to
at least
see how equations can lead you to
these kinds of ideas of an expanding
universe oh i'm going to run out of room
so i'll just write small
an expanding universe and this idea of
the big bang okay so how does this go
well you may recall from an earlier
episode
or from your own knowledge or if this is
completely new i will just tell you
from the outset that einstein
gave us in
his general theory of relativity
an equation which basically
relates the geometry
of the universe so the geometry of
space-time
he relates that through a very precise
equation
to the matter
energy and also momentum pressure
won't write it all down here but the
stuff that's within
space-time itself and by geometry of
space-time what i mean there
is things like
the curvature
of space-time and the size
in some sense the shape of space-time so
all of this
is being related in a precise way to the
matter
and energy that is within space time and
let me just
record that equation for you so
it's r mu nu minus a half
g mu nu r equals eight pi
g over c to the fourth i won't put the c
i'll assume that c is equal to one in
the units that we're using times
t mu nu okay and
the idea is that this left hand side is
a mathematically precise way to talk
about
the curvature of space time
and this t mu nu
stress energy tensor is a precise way to
talk about
the mass and energy within a region
of space time okay so in principle this
is all that we need but let me just
spell out
a couple of the important steps and
important ingredients
that are that go on here so first of all
when we talk about
curvature you may recall in fact i think
i've got a little
yeah i can bring this up here we had a
means of talking about curvature
in terms of something called gamma
a connection again this is an earlier
episode you don't need the details i'll
just
show the idea here so the diagnostic
that we have for curvature
is you take a vector on a shape
and you parallel move it so-called
parallel transported around
a curve that lives in that shape
and the rule the the
methodology for parallel transporting
the vector around
requires that you introduce this thing
called a connection
that connects one location to another
allowing it to slide it around so
when you're in a simple example like
here the two dimensional plane
and if you choose the connection to be
the rule of parallel motion that we all
learn in high school
in high school what do we learn you just
slide the vector so that it points in
the same door and direction
that's the rule it's a very simple rule
but it still is a rule it's an arbitrary
rule
but it's the natural one so we don't
even question it when we're learning in
school
but indeed if we use that particular
rule then indeed if we move
the pink vector around on the plane
when it returns to its starting location
it's going to point
in exactly the same direction as it was
pointing when we started
now you could choose other rules on the
plane you could make a point in a
different direction but let's
keep this as our prototype of the
notion of the plane not having any
curvature
being aligned with this particular
notion of parallel
motion for a sphere it's quite different
as a sphere here you see you can start
with a vector at one given location
and you can now slide that vector around
a loop just as we did on the plane and
we're using a very simple definition of
sliding around keeping its angle with
respect to the
path that it's moving on fixed but look
when you come back to the starting point
on the sphere using that rule for
parallel motion the vector does not
point in the same direction as the
original you have a discrepancy in the
direction which they're pointing
and that's our diagnostic for curvature
that's what we mean
by curvature and let me just head back
over here
for is this up good so there this is
this guy gamma that gives you the rule
for sliding
things around and it's really up to you
to choose
gamma now some of you asked in some
questions in an earlier episode
is it arbitrary can you choose whatever
you want well there are some technical
details but basically in any given
coordinate patch yeah you can choose any
gamma
that you like it's up to you to choose
the definition of parallel motion
however
if you have the notion of a metric and
that's what this guy is
over here this is what is known as a
metric
it's a distance function it allows you
to measure distances
on whatever shape whatever surface
whatever
manifold that you are dealing with if
you have a metric then there is
a unique choice of parallel motion
connection
that is compatible with that metric in
the sense that the lengths of vectors
will not change as you move them
parallel to themselves so
let me just say and that's important
because that's going to pick out a
specific choice of
parallel motion a specific version
of therefore curvature so quickly what
do i mean
by metric it's something that you all
know about from the pythagorean theorem
right according to the pythagorean
theorem if you're in a nice flat space
and you go say delta x this direction
and you go
delta y this direction and then if
you're interested to know the distance
that you've traveled from your starting
point to your ending point
pythagoras tells us that this distance
well let me do the square of the
distance so i don't have to write square
roots
the square of that distance is delta x
squared
plus delta y squared now
that's very specific to a nice flat
surface like
like the two-dimensional plane if you
have
a curved surface
come on don't do that to me notability
there we go
so we have some curved surface like that
and imagine
then you go say delta x this direction
and delta y
this direction and then you're
interested in that
curved distance from your starting point
to your ending location well that's a
pretty ugly looking trajectory let me do
something
like that's a little bit better
what is that distance in terms of delta
x and delta y and in general
it's not delta x squared plus delta y
squared in general it's something of the
form let me just sketch it down here
a number times say delta x squared
another number
times delta y squared plus another
number still
times a cross term so that's the general
form
of the distance relation on say this
curved
surface from the initial to the final
point
and these numbers a b and c
they define what's known as the metric
on this curved space
and these numbers that i have over here
let me use a different color to pull
that out
these numbers that i have over here are
indeed
a matrix it's got two indices mu and new
mu and nu run from one to the dimension
of the space and space time is from
one to four three dimensions of space
and one of time
so mu and nu go from one
to four get rid of that extraneous
fellow over there
they are the analog of these numbers
that i have
over here the a the b and the c in this
little
example but since space time itself can
be curved
and you've got four not two not just a
delta x
then a delta y you've also got a delta z
and a delta t
so you've got four in there so you
therefore have
four by four possibilities where you've
got
say delta t times delta x and delta x
times delta y and delta z times delta x
you've got 16 possibilities it's
actually symmetric so there are 10
numbers
in there and these are the 10 numbers
that give the shape
of space time so now how does the
procedure go
i told you that given a metric there is
a unique
connection such that vectors don't
change their
length under parallel motion so what you
then do
is the procedure is you have
a g the g determines there's a formula
to determine a gamma of g and from gamma
of g
there is a formula and maybe i'll derive
that formula
to get the curvature
as a function of gamma which is itself a
function
of g and the curvature is what
determines
these r's in the left-hand side of
einstein's equation so the bottom line
that i'm driving
at is all of the terms in here on the
left-hand side
are dependent they're dependent on the
metric
and it's various derivatives and that
gives us a differential equation for the
metric an equation for the metric
an equation therefore that talks about
the curvature and the size of space-time
itself
that's that's the key idea and now let
me just
give you an example in the actual
relevant
example for the case of the universe
because
in general once we recognize or assume
or extrapolate from our observations
that the universe namely space time
is homogeneous homogeneous
and isotropic what that means is
it's more or less the same at every
location and it looks the same the
universe looks the same
in basically any direction that you look
isotropic looks the same
regardless of the directions every
location is more or less like every
other on average and that seems to be
the case
in this situation the metric which has
these in principle
16 different components only 10 are
independent because it's symmetric
it reduces down to only one one
component of the metric that's actually
independent and that's what's known as
the scale factor
what is a scale factor you're familiar
with that from any map
you look at a map and the map has a
little legend
in the corner it tells you you know this
separation on the map means 25 miles
or this separation on the map means a
thousand miles it's a scaling
from the actual distances on the map to
distances in the real world
and so if that scale factor were to
change over time
that would in essence mean that the
distances between locations in the real
world
would be changing in time on earth that
doesn't really happen in the universe
it can't so the universe you know it can
do things like this right
there it is i'm now doing it not doing
an expanding universe
which would mean that my scale factor is
growing over time
every location wow this is pretty good i
should have used this for the expanding
universe i never thought about that
every i'm sure some people have done
this before on youtube but there it is
every point is moving away from
every other point and that's coming from
a scale factor that we call
let me give it a name typical name that
is used
is is called a as a function of t
so if a of t were to double in size it
would mean the distances between
galaxies would double from the initial
separation to
the final separation the other thing
that
you have at your disposal besides just
this
scaling factor for the distances between
objects
is the overall shape of the universe
and there are three possibilities that
meet the conditions of homogeneity
and isotropy and they are
the two-dimensional version would be a
sphere a flat plane or
a saddle shape which corresponds to what
we call
k a curvature being 1 0
or -1 appropriately scaled into
these units so these are the two things
that you have the overall shape of space
and the overall size of space so here
you've got shape
and here you've got size and you can
plug this
into einstein's equations this fella
over here
with the stipulation that again g
determines gamma determines curvature
when the dust settles all that
complexity
yields the following relatively simple
looking differential equation which is
let me choose a different color
it's d a of t dt
squared divided by
a again a of t i won't always write it
but a depends upon time as a whole point
equals 8 pi g i'll tell you what
rho is and have to use the energy
density divided by 3
minus k over a
squared okay
so the key term in here and again
it makes perfect sense this is energy
density i should never write script it
looks awful but anyway energy density
that makes sense look at the
right hand side of the einstein
equations is
the amount of matter energy in a region
of space
and indeed therefore we have this on the
right hand side and here's k
the shape of space so it's either one
zero minus one depending on
whether it's a sphere the analog of a
plane the analog of
a saddle okay so now now we're cooking
with gas
because we can we can do some
calculations
now first off let me note the following
is it possible that d a d t is equal to
zero can you get a static universe
well you can right because if you were
to play these two terms
off of each other if say the density
of energy and let's say this is a
positive number k
so that this term minus this term could
be equal to zero
you can do that and einstein played this
game this is what gave rise to
the so-called einstein static universe
and this is why einstein
perhaps had this view that the universe
was
static and unchanging but what i believe
friedman also pointed out to einstein is
that's an unstable solution so you might
be able to balance
these two terms against each other but
it's sort of like balancing
my apple pencil on the surface of the
ipad i might do it for a split second
but once the pencil moves one way or
another it just topples over
similarly if the size of the universe
were to change
for whatever reason just be perturbed by
a little bit
then this is an unstable solution the
universe would start to expand
or contract so so that that's
not the kind of universe that we imagine
that we live in
instead let's now look at some solutions
that
are stable at least long term stable
just so you can see how this equation
yields the particular way that space
will change
in time so let me just for argument's
sake to the simple case that k
is equal to zero and let me get rid of
the einstein static universe stuff that
we have over here
so now we are just looking at the
equation
d a dt
say is equal two of d dt squared
is equal to 8 pi g rho
over 3 times a of t
squared and let's imagine
that the energy density of the universe
comes
from matter just for argument's sake
i'll do radiation in a second
and and matter has say a fixed amount of
total
matter spread through a volume v right
so the energy density
would come from the total mass in
the stuff that's filling space divided
by the volume now volume of course goes
like
a of t cubed right so
this then is something which drops like
the uh cube of the separation
let's now put that in this equation over
here to see what we get if you don't
mind i'm going to drop
all constants i just want to get the
overall
time dependence i don't care about
getting the details of the
precise numerical coefficients
as well so i'm just going to put d a dt
squared equals so putting the row
has an a cubed on the bottom you got an
a squared over here
so we'll have d a d t going like one
over a of t
and let me not put an equal sign there
let me just put a nice
little squiggly that we often use to say
roundabout
captures the qualitative feature that we
are looking at now how do we solve this
guy
well let me just take a of t
to be some power law t to the alpha
let's see if we can find an alpha such
that this equation is satisfied
so d a d t that will give us a t to the
alpha
minus one again dropping all the terms
in front squared
this goes like one over a of t would be
t to the minus
alpha so that would be t to the two
alpha
minus two goes like t to the minus alpha
for that to be true
two alpha minus two has to be equal to
minus
alpha that means three alpha equals two
and therefore alpha equals two thirds
and therefore we now have our solution
that a of t
goes like t to the two thirds there it
is
this shape of the universe we chose it
to be the flat
version the analog of the
two-dimensional plane but a
three-dimensional version
and einstein's equations do the rest and
tell us
that the size the separation of points
on that flat three-dimensional shape
grow as the two-thirds power of the time
sorry i wish i had some water around
here i'm getting so worked up
by uh the solution to einstein's
equation that i'm losing my voice
but there you have it right so that's
kind of beautiful right oh
man that water tasted really bad i think
it may have been sitting out here for a
few days
so if i if i should uh should faint
during the
remaining portion of this little episode
you know where it came from
but in any event look how beautiful this
is we now have
aft an actual
functional form for the size of the
universe that is the separation i really
call it the separation between points on
this universe separation between
galaxies
given by t to the two thirds now notice
that as t goes to zero
a of t goes to zero and that's his idea
of
infinite density back at the big bang
things that are
finite separation at any given moment in
time they're all crushed together
time goes to zero because a of t goes to
zero now of course i made the assumption
here
that the energy density came from
matter and that therefore has a density
that drops like the volume drops like a
t cubed
let me just do one more case for the fun
of it that
we often focus our attention on because
it's actually physically relevant
which is radiation radiation is a little
bit different
it's energy density doesn't go like
1 over a cubed
instead it goes like 1 over a of t
to the 4th why is there an extra factor
of
a relative to this one over here the
reason is because
as the universe expands light beams
themselves
stretch as well so that
is an additional decrease in their
energy longer wavelength
less energy remember energy
goes like h times nu nu is the frequency
nu goes like one over lambda c over
lambda c is equal to one
so as lambda gets bigger
the energy drops and it drops in
proportional
to the scale factor which is the degree
to which things
stretch out and that's why you get a one
over a cubed as you would
for matter but you get one additional
factor of a
from the stretching okay bottom line is
we can now go back to our equation just
as we did before
and now the only difference will be
instead of having a 1 over a of t
that we had from rho going like
1 over a cubed times the a squared rho
goes like 1 over a to the 4th
times a squared so we'll have an a
squared in the bottom so
all comes down to that the equation
is d a dt squared
goes like 1 over a of t
squared so let's play the same game
let's say a of t
let's guess that it has a power law
dependence
the adt gets an alpha minus one upstairs
square that you get a two alpha minus
two
you have a one over a of t squared
that's a t to the minus
two alpha for this to work you must have
two alpha minus two
equals minus two alpha or four alpha
is equal to two or alpha equals one-half
and there you have that result so in
this case for radiation
a of t would go like t to the one-half
power
and indeed if you think about it if you
want in the cosmic film in reverse
having a one over a to the fourth power
over here
means as a gets smaller this is going to
get bigger faster
than the corresponding density of matter
which only has an a cubed in the bottom
and therefore as you go further and
further back in time ultimately
radiation will dominate
over matter when it comes to the energy
density
so this will be the time dependence
as you get closer and closer to the big
bang but again
the point is as t goes to zero you still
have a of t
going to zero so you still have the
situation
of this infinitely dense starting
configuration
out of which the universe then expands
giving rise to the big bang
now let me finish up here by just making
one point you could still ask the
question
already so way back toward the beginning
we see that these equations you know
have everything on top of each other
this approach if you will toward
infinite density
but what actually is it that drove the
outward swelling of space why did this
happen
at all what is the outward pushing
force that drove everything to swell
outwards and einstein's equation doesn't
actually give you an
answer to that we are basically seeing
that behavior emerge from the equations
but if you go way back to time zero like
you can't have
infinite density we don't really know
excuse me what that means
so you need a deeper understanding of
what's going on you need something to
really supply
the outward push that drove the
expansion of space
to begin and ultimately then to be
described
dynamically by science equations i'm
going to come back to that that takes us
to
inflationary cosmology it takes us to
this idea of repulsive gravity it takes
us as well
to the modern realization that there is
a thing called
dark energy driving the accelerated
expansion of space in this description
it would not be accelerated
so we have a some still some very rich
fertile territory
to to wander through which we will in
subsequent episodes
but i hope this gives you some sense not
only of the
intuitive imagery of what we mean by
an expanding universe the history of how
we got to it but also it's kind of nice
i hope for you to see
how some simple mathematical equations
can tell us something about the entirety
of
the universe now look this is heavy
stuff i agree this is heavy stuff
but but just imagine that
kids can can not just solve equations
in the math class but somehow be
inspired to realize that the equations
that they're solving
can tell us about the expansion of the
universe
i don't know it just strikes me that
that's the kind of thing
that i know i'm being naive but that no
no kid wouldn't get excited by and i
hope that you
even if you didn't follow all the
details got excited about how some very
simple equations properly interpreted
easy to solve give us this implication
of an expanding universe
and take us to this notion of a big bang
okay
that's it for today that is your daily
equation
pick it up with the next episode
probably on
an inflation or dark energy
the repulsive side of gravity but until
then take care